hello you're playing the waiting game
the show that distracts you with
substitute games films and other such
stuff bully wait for the farmer exciting
main event much like how I'm here to
distract you until Seb returns from his
skiing holiday Oh made myself feel bad
well you know what screw that he's not
the only one who can go off gallivanting
let's show him by taking a trip of our
very own so pack your bags everybody
we're taking a trip to London for the
order 1886 yeah yes Greg we're already
in London metaphor Greg set in an
alternative history Victorian London the
order 1886 puts you in the rather
fetching leather boots of four nights
tasked with keeping the world safe from
a race of half human half animal hybrids
the war between mankind of mutants has
been raging for centuries with the
latter side generally having the upper
hand probably because it's got massive
animal claws on it however thanks to the
recent explosion of the Industrial
Revolution blows metaphor again Greg the
scales have been tipped back in favor of
the one hundred percent humans mainly
thanks to the production of an array of
badass mechanical / supernatural weapons
and technologies
as if the war between man and man beast
wasn't trouble enough a new internal
conflict has also arisen a class war
with the poor oppressed masses rebelling
against the rich nobles and as a member
of the order it's your job to protect
the well-to-do the whole thing is
looking rather promising although we do
have quite a way in our hands as we
shouldn't really expect to see the
release till the latter half of this
year at the earliest fortunately for you
then I have the perfect game to consider
if you're looking to immerse yourself in
a bleak pseudo Victorian setting and
what a game it is without doubt one of
my favorite releases of the last few
years dishonored play sees you in the
supernatural stealth assassin bits of
corvo attano former bodyguard to the
Empress framed for her murder you must
exact your revenge on those responsible
one gruesome assassination after another
or not there's always a non-lethal
option to the game setting is the city
of dumb wall now while it's not
technically the British capital it is
heavily influenced by Victorian era
London and also my home city of
Edinburgh interestingly the done in
dunwall presumably comes from Dunedin
the scots gaelic name for the city
the wall is undergoing a technological
revolution of its own driven by the
industrial processing of whale oil this
freshly squeezed mammal juice has some
distinctly supernatural qualities to it
and has led to the creation of a ton of
advanced weaponry for the upper classes
this in turn has led to a class war
which dominates life in done well with
the poor increasingly ravaged by the
deadly plague sweeping the city while
the rich normal men and women sit safe
in their fortified mansions it's a
ridiculously fun game that rewards
experimentation and exploration also
stabbing people in the neck I can't
recommend highly enough if first-person
stealth isn't your thing though when you
still find yourself hankering for the
atmosphere of the order why not check
out from hell the graphic novel that is
don't bother yourself with a forgettable
movie though unless you have time for a
comedy of accents from Depp and Heather
Graham who their most believable sounds
like a couple of Marty bookies my sure
refresh but the graphic novel oh the
graphic novel is excellent based on the
hand pen letter of the same name
believed by many to be an authentic
message from the Ripper himself as
transcribed by his faithful albeit
reluctant comin John netley the story
follows the scandals on consequences of
a secret an illegitimate royal baby
Queen Victoria hires a freemason named
goal to silence all evidence of the
tryst allowing him legal immunity and a
free license for his butcher liebrand of
assassinations who's gonna bust the
whole case wide open a hardy combo of
Abilene and Lee's as much as that sounds
like a taxi service or a monthly veg
subscription the unlikely combination of
met police inspector and psychic proofs
fairly formidable and it isn't long
until their neck deep in conspiracy buy
it you won't feel ripped off get it
ripped ripper because Jack the Ripper
okay movie time now we're yet to get a
good look at the beastmen from the order
but in the most recent cinematic trailer
we did get a glimpse of one of our furry
friends now if that's not a werewolf
I'll eat my metaphorical hat now I know
what you're thinking that movie wolfman
sounds ideal right well no
it's rubbish distinctly less rubbish
however and even more wolfy is dog
soldiers now don't go into this film
expecting pedigree cinema this is an
unashamed b-movie but a b-movie helmed
by neil marshall no less the director
responsible for the descent which was
pretty damn kids like the descent Dog
Soldiers was filmed in Scotland
and whilst the former got it scares from
the little ghouls underground Dog
Soldiers find screams in the furry
buggers above it in a plot that through
as a hard-as-nails British Army squad
into what could be described as
Goldilocks cottage you can imagine it's
not light on the ridiculous and most
certainly doesn't cheap out on the
thrills ever it's a taste of a
third-person cover-based shooting that
we've seen in the order that you're
after then I reckon your best bet is to
check out the last of us now this might
seem like a bizarre recommendation but
if you take a close look at what we've
seen from the orders gameplay looks
claustrophobic frantic and above all
else kind of brutal action in the last
of us has this in spades for the
uninitiated the last of us tells the
combined story of Joel and Ellie two
survivors in a world ravaged by a deadly
cordyceps fungal infection the disease
terms normally Pleasant everyday folk
into a variety of terrifying in violent
zombie mushroom type things another good
reason to suspect that these two games
might have more in common than first
glance suggests comes from an interview
with one of the developers from ready at
dawn they commented that it was the
feeling they had after completing
Naughty Dog's other masterpiece
uncharted two among thieves that
inspired the development of the order
not that you should really need an
excuse to play the last of us to be
honest it's exceptional on one of the
finest games of last year okay last
recommendation for you today is the 2002
Martin Scorsese epic gangs of new york
why well it's not the foggy historical
setting the muskets classic clothing and
violence no no it's the fact that one of
the main protagonists is blatantly
Daniel day-lewis look no question and
there's no question that Daniel
day-lewis is bloody fantastic and a good
enough reason to watch any of the films
he started on my challenge by the
ancient laws of combat we are met at
this chosen ground to settle for good
know who holds sway over the five points
in this case he plays bill the butcher a
fine whiskered and sadistic overlord
defending his territory from the irish
immigrant gang the dead rabbits taking
new recruit amsterdam played by mr.
DiCaprio under his wing he's unbeknownst
the
that he is the son of an old and
defeated rival in the throes of a
long-awaited revenge plot much
backstabbing asst both literal and
otherwise ensues I'm gonna paint
paradise squirrel with his Bob so that's
it for another waiting game let me know
what you thought of this week's
recommendations in the comments down
below or reach out to me on Twitter why
not at camp fraz Rob mr. Seb Ford will
return next week so I guess that's
goodbye forever